this is a what is this a religious
artifact what is this this is beautiful
that's my glass right there that's what
i drink out of that's
that's a fine glass
we can't get in tight because we're not
on cable but uh it's a
it's
nice
okay i guess we just did
it's very very nice how are you thanks
for coming back i'm doing smoove how are
you i'm doing smooth too
see we could hang together couldn't we
yes sir
it's never going to happen
congratulations your movie training day
25 million a weekend it's doing great
you must be really happy
he's doing great
yeah that's cool you are acting you're
you're doing music of course still
you're producing you have a line of
clothes what is what is next i have a
theme park i'm working on called doggy
land
you really have a theme park yeah i want
to do something special for the kids man
tell us what happens at doggy land
well i mean i mean you bring the kids
there and they have a good time you know
what i'm saying that's what it's all
about i know i want to hear some
specifics about what's happening at
doggy land what kind of ride can we
expect i got one ride called the
40-ounce slide
[Laughter]
40. so it's you get in a 40-ounce can
and you slide down exactly good time for
the whole family it's outside
now is there going to be uh theme
characters like minnie and mickey mouse
people like that walking around um
no i'm just going to be me and all my
dogs just you and all your dogs where
are you going to put this theme park i
don't know yet i'm thinking about
putting it in mississippi
this would be so cool i mean dolly
parton did it a lot of different people
have done it i'm working on one the
plans keep falling through
no one wants to go to mine but it sounds
that sounds really exciting are you
serious about it you might do it
somebody help me please
[Laughter]
talk about bones you've got this movie
it's a horror film
do you like horror films yeah i grew up
a fan of them as a kid so i mean when i
was given the opportunity to play a
horror flick character
you know what i'm saying i was like i'm
with it right
now of course they always release the
good horror films around halloween
halloween's coming up what is snoop dogg
doing on halloween
i'm gonna be taking my kids i'll trick
or treat
that's cool how many kids do you have
that's nice
you've talked to
do you have you have three kids yeah
three kids what do they dress up as
one of them love scooby doo
and the other one loved tony hawk the
skateboarder and my daughter just want
to be like barbie supposed to be like a
barbie doll yeah so you take them around
what what did you used to dress up as
when you go out on halloween i like
batman
batman
what else besides batman a ghost if i
didn't have enough money for a costume
ghost is always like the good fallback
position exactly in my house it was
any cardboard box and you could be a
robot if you poke your arms from like
bleep bleep
it says frigidaire on the front
um
you have a love interest in this movie
bones tell us about about her uh the
lovely pam greer
she's my love venture she's somebody who
i grew up wanting to you know just meet
me
[Applause]
nice save there
yeah but she she's the one you know i'm
saying she did an exceptional job i want
to give her a shout out right now if she
at home watching this
now you have a kissing scene with her
what was that like
man my heart was beating so fast
but i handled it though i took care of
my business believe that
now
did you have to square things with your
wife beforehand was that it was that was
it cool with her well actually pam
called my wife and told her what was
happening
like to sort of talk her through it say
it's okay yeah i'm you know i've never
done this i'm just new to the movie
world so she was more professional about
it than i was that's cool so she just
told everything's going to be all right
yeah she wasn't calling to taunt her no
okay
um you
this movie was shot in was he shot in
canada in vancouver yeah vancouver have
you hung out have you
okay um
have you uh have you hung out in in
canada much oh yeah after that i went
and shot a video out there um
went out there for a few basketball
games i love it out there
because the people they there's a very
specific kind of dialect they're
speaking english but you know they say
like a and things like that were you
were you picking up on that when you
were up there i didn't pick up no a but
i picked up the green
you bought astroturf
[Laughter]